I feel it's my duty under parliamentary
privilege to name Philip green as the
individual in question given the man who
spoke out so publicly a day on Lord
Haines is now facing a backlash for his
choice to do so after outing Sir Philip
as the person who prevented the
Telegraph publishing allegations of
sexual and racial harassment it's now
emerged Lord Haines is an advisor to the
law firm representing the newspaper he's
provided no proper explanation for his
actions apart from his own opinion which
I find breathtakingly arrogant what is
the point then of having courts there
isn't any because he can make his pick
any time he likes or has information in
order to destroy a court case and
circumvent a court order it cannot be
justified in a statement Lord Haines
says I took the decision to name sir
Phillip green in my personal capacity as
an independent member of the House of
Lords I categorically state I was
completely unaware Gordon dads were
advising the Telegraph regarding this
case Gordon dads are highly respect and
reputable international law firm played
absolutely no part whatsoever in either
the sourcing of my information or my
independent decision to name sir Phillip
they were completely unaware of my
intentions until after I spoke in the
House of Lords meanwhile aroused brewing
between two institutions at odds with
one another on the one side the
judiciary which granted an injunction
and on the other Parliament which
superseded it whether it was in the
public interest or not is something that
the courts were going to look at when
they had the time and when they had the
full evidence available I would have
thought that that's now impossible and
therefore he is substituting his view of
the public interest for the courts view
of the public interest mr. speaker with
about 75,000 people having named Ryan
Giggs on Twitter it's not the first time
parliamentary privilege has been used to
override an injunction in 2011 MP John
hemming named footballer Ryan Giggs as
having had an alleged affair freedom of
speech empowerment is not
it's controlled by Parliament and I
don't think anyone would like to see a
situation in which Parliament didn't
have the freedom for people to speak out
and raise concerns of the issues of the
day Sir Philip Green categorically
denies the allegations but his case has
raised divisions between lawmakers and
judges on one fundamental question who
should decide when someone accused of a
crime is named Adele Robinson Sky News